H
YEAH. THE PEOPLE. THANK YOU.
UHHUH.
CALLED. YEAH OKAY. SYRIA
ON. AT. YEAH.
OVER. RIGHT RIGHT.
YEAH. YEAH. AT. OKAY. AFTER.
IT'S NOT. YEAH RIGHT. OUR. HM.
YEAH. YEAH.
YEAH.
ON.
ALL. R.
OR.
THREE ISRAEL ARE YOU KNOW.
THE WINNER FOR REVISION AFTER.
OKAY.
YEAH. YEAH CATERPIE.
READERS. YEAH YEAH.
RIGHT.
WHAT
HAPPENED EVERYONE- WHEN THE
SENATE LAST ACTED. WITH REGARD
TO COVID NINETEEN BACK IN MARCH
AND APRIL. WE HAD AT THAT POINT
ADDED. ABOUT THREE TRILLION
DOLLARS THE MASS DEBT WE'VE
DONE OF COURSE. AND OTHER DATA
SAAGAR FOR THE FIRST SINCE. OR
FOR TWO YEARS AND I LOVE IT SO.
CONCERNING SO I SAID I THOUGHT
WE NEEDED TO PUSH THE PAUSE
BUTTON. BEGIN TO SEE THE IMPACT
OF THE CARRIAGE ACT AND RELATED
ACTS THE FASTER IN THAT PERIOD.
SEE HOW WE DID ONE DAY ECONOMY
BEGAN TO RE OPEN. AND TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT WHAT THE
COUNTRY NEEDED. AND A LOT.
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE MANAGED SENATE
REPUBLICANS ADMINISTRATION HAVE
BEEN CONSULTING OVER THE LAST
FEW WEEKS. TO COME UP WITH A
REALISTIC PROPOSAL. WITH WHAT
WE THINK IS APPROPRIATE. AMOUNT
OF ADDITIONAL DEATH TO BE ADDED.
OKAY THE ECONOMY AT THE TIME.
WE CAN GO TO ABOUT A TRILLION
DOLLARS. AND WE'VE ALLOCATED
THAT IN A WAY THAT WE TECH
MAKES THE MOST SENSE. FOR THE
COUNTRY AT THIS PARTICULAR TIME.
IT WILL INCLUDE LIABILITY
INSURANCE. WHICH SENATOR
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS WHICH ARE
RECORDED GONNA DESCRIBE HERE
SHORTLY. BUT LET ME JUST MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT WON'T BE A BILL
THAT PASSED THE SENATE IT
DOESN'T HAVE THIS ON A- ALREADY
BEEN THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
LAWSUITS FILED THE COUNTRY
CANNOT STAND AN EPIDEMIC OF
LOSSES ON THE FIELD. OF THE
PANDEMIC WERE ALREADY WORKING
OUR WAY THROUGH. SO WITH THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE. DEVELOPED A VERY OF
COMPONENT PARTS OF OUR PROPOSAL
AND I'M NOT CERTAIN WHO COME
SECOND. WE NOTICED THAT.
INITIAL SIMILAR. GOLDMAN
MAPUCHE. SANDRA. TWO NUMBER ONE
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT PAYMENTS. THERE
WERE MADE IN APRIL AND MAY. R.
S. THAT MEANS THAT THE AVERAGE
FAMILY OF FOUR WILL- COULDN'T
WILL GET ANOTHER PAYMENT OF
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS IT
INCLUDES. JUST A FEW PEOPLE
THAT WERE- UNINTENTIONALLY LEFT
OUT OF THE LAST ONE MOSTLY
DEPENDENCE COLLEGE AND ADULTS
THAT ARE SOMEBODY ELSE'S
DEPENDED. WE EXTEND ADDITIONAL.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. AND
REMEMBER THAT'S ON TOP OF WHAT
EVER THE DIFFERENT FIFTY STATES
GIVE. HI AND ON TOP OF THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT STATEMENT I
JUST GAVE SO WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO HELP THE UNEMPLOYED
WHAT WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE WORK
AND WE'VE LEARNED A VERY
UNPLEASANT THAT WHEN YOU PAY
PEOPLE NOT TO WORK. WHAT DO YOU
EXPECT. AND SO THIS PAYMENT
WILL BE ADJUSTED SO THAT WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS TO
HELP PEOPLE FOR PARTIALLY 7275%
OF THEIR- INCO THAT'S NOT MEDIA.
WITH. WELL IT SOUNDS JUST LIKE
MINE YEAH. THERE ARE MANY.
WE'RE ALL WE'RE GOING TO- HAVE
FURTHER- TAX RELIEF FOR
BUSINESSES TO ENCOURAGE HIRING
AND REHIRING AND- WE WILL. WE
WANT TO DO THAT A COURAGE
PEOPLE TO GET BACK TO WORK AND
HELP MORE IN THE PROCESS
SUPPORT PEOPLE IN THE MEANTIME
SUPPORT PATIENTS IN NURSING
HOMES AND- AND ALSO FOSTER YOU.
FLEXIBILITY AND HOUSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN USE FEDERAL
RELIEF FUNDS INCLUDING AN
ABILITY TO USE FUNDS TO COVER
REVENUE SHORTFALLS. AND THAT IS.
SOMEBODY DOESN'T WANT ME TO GET
ON TELEVISION RIGHT ON THE LEFT.
PROBABLY NOT ATTEND. WHY DIDN'T
YOU TELL ME THAT. A MEMBER OF
I'M SORRY. LASTLY I HOPE THAT
DEMOCRATS WILL COME TO THE
TABLE AND WE WORK OUT A
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CALLED. THAT WE- WELL
WE ALL KNOW THIS IS OF ROUND
ONE WE BELIEVE THAT AS THE
LEADER SAID IT'S CENTERED
RATIONALLY AND OTHERS WILL SAY
THIS IS A THIS IS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO HELP GET HIM
BACK TO WORK KEEP THEM AT WORK
GET HIM BACK JUST TO KEEP THEM
IN SCHOOL AS SAFELY AS WE CAN
WE'VE ALREADY. PUT OUT A LOT OF
MONEY THESE STORE THESE ARE
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES- I KNOW THE
HOUSE HAS IT HAS A BIGGER
FIGURE THAN THE S. AND THEN
THIS IS ON WILL HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH OVERALL WE THINK THIS
IS A PRETTY GOOD PACKAGE AND I
HOPE THAT THIS IN A POP WEDDING
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH. CARAHER
THANK YOU THE MOST OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE BILL HAVE
MEETING WHEN ADDED TO SENATOR
BLUNT'S APPROPRIATIONS BILL SO
I'LL JUST SPEAK ABOUT THREE-
STUDENT LOANS SCHOOL CHOICE
AND- CHILDCARE. OUR IN MARCH.
BUT CONGRESS AGREED THAT IT THE
FORTY THREE MILLION AMERICANS
WHO HAVE A STUDENT LOAN WOULD
NOT HAVE TO PAY A MONTHLY
PAYMENT UNTIL OCTOBER THE FIRST
PAYMENT WOULD BE DEFERRED UNTIL
IT WOULD BE FOR. OCTOBER ONE IS
JUST AROUND THE CORNER SO WHAT
WE PROPOSES. IF YOU HAVE NO
INCOME. YOU HAVE NO MONTHLY
PAYMENTS. IF YOU DO HAVE IN
COMMON THEN WE'LL CHANGE THE
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENT SYSTEM SO
THAT YOU NEVER HAVE TO PAY MORE
THAN 10% OF YOUR INCOME AFTER
YOU'VE DEDUCTED THE SISTERS OF
LIFE LIKE MORTGAGE AND FOR.
SECOND ON SCHOOL CHOICE THEY'RE
ABOUT. HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS IN THE COUNTRY THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND PRIVATE SCHOOLS
ARE THOUSAND PUBLIC ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION CHILDREN IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FIVE POINT SEVEN IN THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS GENERALLY
SPEAKING WE THINK EVERY CHILD
IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT AND- SHOW
WHAT WE PROPOSE IS ABOUT
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS. FOR
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH THE
TWELFTH GRADE. AND THIRTY MORE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR COLLEGES.
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
EDUCATION IS ABOUT THE SAME AS
THE HOUSE PASSED BILL. SO THERE
COULD BE AN AREA OF AGREEMENT.
ASCENDER ONE WILL SAY WE I
BELIEVE THAT EVERY SCHOOL
SHOULD GET SOME MONEY WOULD BE
ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER PERSON ON K. THROUGH
TWELVE. EVERY SCHOOL SHOULD GET
A THIRD OF THAT- EVEN IF
THEY'RE OPENING VIRTUAL AND THE
REST OF THAT MONEY SHOULD GO TO
SCHOOLS THAT ARE MAKING AN
EFFORT TO OPEN AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. WE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
FOR MANY MORE EXPENSES WHEN
YOU'RE PHYSICALLY PRESENT. LESS
IS MORE TEACHERS MORE SPACE OR
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT WE BELIEVE
WE OUGHT TO PAY. PAY FOR THAT
ON SCHOOL CHOICE- SENATOR SCOTT
HAS A BILL WHICH SHE WILL
DISCUSS AND I'M A CO SPONSOR OF
THAT WHICH WOULD- GIVE PARENTS
MORE CHOICES OF ALL SCHOOLS.
AND CHILDCARE- CHILDCARE
CENTERS HAVING A HARD TIME
STAYING OPEN BECAUSE THEY HAVE
LESS REVENUE FEWER STUDENTS AND
THERE NEED TO BE MORE SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS FOR CHILDCARE. AND
FINALLY FOR SPENDING A LOT OF
MONEY TO BUILD A MANUFACTURING
BASE VERY FRACTURING PLANTS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IN THE
FUTURE THEY'RE NOT IN CHINA WE
INTEGRATE VACCINES AND IN THE
FUTURE WE WANNA MAKE SURE WE
HAVE PLENTY OF MASS. AND OTHER
WOMEN IN OUR STOCK POPS SO WE
AUTHORIZED THAT IS WELL THIS IS
A BILL ABOUT. BACK TO BACK TO
JOHN BACK TO WORK. DONALD. THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM HAS
BEEN A LIFELINE TO MORE THAN
FIVE MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES NATIONWIDE
IN THE STATE OF MAINE NEARLY
THREE QUARTERS OF ALL SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE RECEIVED THESE
FORGIVABLE LOANS THAT HAVE
SUSTAINED THE GE ABS TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND BEING.
RIGHT MORE TWO TO BILLION
DOLLARS TO THE STATE OF MAINE
WE ARE TODAY PROPOSING A SECOND
ROUND OF THE PPP LOANS FOR THE
HARDEST HIT SMALL BUSINESSES
JUST THIS MORNING I WAS TALKING
TO IN THE INNKEEPER MAIN WHO
TOLD ME THAT AT THIS TIME OF
YEAR USUALLY HIS SAND WOULD BE
BOOKED SOLID EVERY SINGLE
NIGHT. INSTEAD BUSINESS IS DOWN
BY 93% SO WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING
IS THAT HARDEST HIT SMALL
BUSINESSES THOSE WITH REVENUE
LOSSES OF 50% OR MORE CAMPAIGN
TO LAST YEAR WOULD BE ABLE TO
READ C. AS AGAIN P. P. P. LOAN
TIM IS STAYING THERE. IS AN
ISSUE WITH HAVE THIRTEEN OVER.
SINCE ANOTHER IMPORT THEY
SHOULDN'T A LACK HOUSE PPP
OVERHEAD FENCE TO BE USED OR
RENT. THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
COMPLY WITH THESE I. THE PERSON
PROTECTIVE OKAY. SUCH AS MASKS
ARE A LOT. AND OTHER RANDOM.
THAT MAY BE TO END THE SAFETY
OF BOTH THE EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
AND CUSTOMERS THAT WILL BE
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL TO
RESTAURANTS FOR EXAMPLE BETTER
STILL UNDER STRICT RESTRICTIONS.
THERE IS ALSO A LONG TERM LOAN
COMPONENT OF THE BILL THAT
WE'VE INTRODUCED AND SENATOR
RUBIO'S GOING TO EXPLAIN THAT
WHEN HE GETS HERE I DON'T THINK
HE SYRIA- BUT ARGUABLY THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL PROVISIONS OF
BIG CARES ACT AND I'M
DELIGHTED. THAT WE INTRODUCE. I
EXTENSION OF IT. GRAHAM. ONE
THANKS MAJOR PUT THIS TOGETHER
LAST TIME WE DIDN'T DO MUCH
ABOUT CHINA THIS TIME WE ARE SO
WHAT WE LEARNED 90% OF THE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THAT ARE
DOCTORS AND NURSES AND
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS NEED
TO KEEP US SAFE AND KEEP THEIR
FAMILY SAFE IS MADE IN CHINA SO
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HELL BENT ON
TRYING TO BRING THE MEDICAL
SUPPLY CHAIN BACK THERE'S A BIG
STEP FORWARD IN THIS BILL- WITH
A SEVEN AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT TO
INCENTIVIZE VP- KEY MATERIAL TO
BE MADE IN THE UNITED STATES
GLOVES MASK AND SENATE LEADERS
BETTING. SEVEN AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR TAX CREDIT MODEL
OFF THE ENERGY TAX CREDIT WOULD
THINK THAT I HAVE A BIG EFFECT
ON BRING THIS BLOCKCHAIN BACK
UNDER THE VERY- BUT THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT AMERICAN
MILITARY UNIFORMS BE MADE IN
AMERICA ONE OF THE P. E. EAT
UNDER THAT SO THE NATIONAL
STOCKPILE HAVE PROTECTED THAT
MADE AMERICA YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
DOWN CHINA SEN ALCOR HAS GYPPED
OKAY. GOOD INDUSTRY ALL THE
OTHER WE'RE TRYING TO GET BACK.
I MADE. THAT'S OKAY. EXAM YOU
CAN HERE WHICH OPTION ANOTHER
WAY CENTER GUY A THAT I THINK
IT'S MY NEEDED TO PEOPLE STILL
IN PROPERTY AND AMERICA THERE A
CAN AROUND RESEARCH DEVELOP AND
PENALTIES FOR THOSE BAD ACTORS
WHO TRIED IT'S THEIR WAGES. AND
VALLEY US CINEMA CASKEY LIVES
IN ALASKA THERE ARE A LOT OF
PRECIOUS CRITICAL METALS AND
MATERIALS THAT AMERICA HAS BUT
WE DO A VERY POOR JOB OF
GETTING IT OUT OF THE GROUND
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND WAY
MORE BECOMING MORE DEPENDENT ON
CHINA AND OTHER PLACES IN THE
WORLD FOR CRITICAL MINERALS AND
WE GOT A PLAN TO BECOME MORE
AMERICAN MADE IN ON THEIR-
CURRENT. ONE I THINK ABOUT 25%
OF THE BILLS AND THE LABOR AGE
EDUCATION SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY- BILLION
DOLLARS NONE OF THAT MONEY
THAT'S THERE WAS THERE WITHOUT
THE INPUT FROM GERMAN SHELBY
AND CHAIRMAN ALEXANDER WHO
CHAIRS THE AUTHORIZING
COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY CHAIRMAN
SHELBY SURE CHAIRS A COUPLE
COMMITTEE ON THE EDUCATION
FRONT I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
BEEN TALKED ABOUT ENOUGH YOU'LL
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ON THAT
LATER ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION
PARKING THIRTY BILLION OR SO
THE GOES TO. HIGHER EDUCATION
THAT MONEY WILL GO OUT ON THE
F. T. E. BASIS TO OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES AND WE'LL GO
OUT QUICKLY WE HOPE- AND MANY
OF THEM ARE GOING TO RE OPEN AS
EARLY AS THE TENTH OF AUGUST OR
SO WE NEED TO GET THAT MONEY
OUT OF THE- HIRING THE OF
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY MONEY.
THE TWO THIRDS BEING HELD BACK
FOR STUPID PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO GET IN PERSON
EDUCATION REINSTATED AGAIN A
LOT OF THAT MONEY ALSO CAN GO
OUT QUICKLY UNDER OUR BILL
YEAH- AT LEAST 50% OF YOUR
STUDENTS ARE IN PERSON 50% OF
THE TIME YOU QUALIFY
IMMEDIATELY FOR THE SECOND TWO
THIRDS OF THE MONEY THAT WOULD
COME TO YOUR SCHOOL- AND- IF
IT'S LESS THAN THAT HAS TO BE
EXPLAINED IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
LEFT UP TO GOVERNORS AND THE
EDUCATION IN THE STATE TO WORK
ON THAT ON THE HEALTH FRONT WE
HAVE ABOUT TWENTY WE HAVE
SIXTEEN BIT IN NEW DOLLARS
WHICH IS A TOTAL OF TWENTY FIVE
BILLION. OUR PRIORITY TO HELP
TEST THROUGH THE STATE. IS PAPA.
PRIOR ON ELLEN AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
ON NURSING HOMES AND CHILDCARE
FACILITIES. CHILDCARE
FACILITIES ALSO GET- THE LOT OF
ATTENTION THIS BILL FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN CHILD CARE
FACILITIES. THAT FRANKLY HAVE
A- OF. WORK MODEL THAT DOESN'T
WORK AT FORTY FIVE AND 50%
WHICH IS THE LIKELY CHILDCARE
ENROLLMENT AS PEOPLE GET BACK
TO WORK SOME PEOPLE WANT TO
SEND THEIR KIDS OTHER PEOPLE
WILL STILL BE LOOKING FOR WORK
THEMSELVES- AND SO TRYING TO.
HELP GET THE NUMBERS AND THE
SPACE TO MATCH THEY'LL BE SOME
CHILDCARE EXPENSES OF
DISTANCING AND OTHER THINGS
THAT HAVE TO BE DONE BUT YOU
CAN'T GET BACK TO WORK IF YOU
CAN'T GET BACK TO CHILD CARE
FOR MOST FAMILIES. THE END OF
YOUR WORKING PARENT
PARTICULARLY PURE WORKING
SINGLE PARENT. YOUR BIGGEST
SINGLE PROBLEM IS MAKING SURE
THAT THAT CHILD CARE SITUATION
WORKS HOW WE PUT TWICE AS MONEY
IN OUR YOU KNOW TWICE AS MUCH
MONEY IN OUR BILL- AS THE HOUSE
DID IN HEROES ACT- AND WE'LL BE
TALKING FROM MOVING. FROM THAT
POINT. ANOTHER THIRTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN OUR BILL
GOES TO OTHER ADVANCE EXCHANGE
THERE. PARTICULARLY ARE HOPING
JUNE ALWAYS HAVE PAINS OUT
THERE ARE UP THERE ABOUT REP
THE OF FIRST NEXT YEAR A IN
DOING WE'RE GOING TO SOME
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA MOVE FOR.
WITH PRODUCING SOME VACCINES WE
THINK WILL GET FULL FDA
APPROVAL THAT JUST WON'T WORK
OUT. MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT WE
THANK FOR LIKELY TO WORK
KNOWING THEY WEREN'T ALL FOR
ALL WORK. BUT ALSO NO ONE WANTS
TO DO WORK WILL BE AVAILABLE
MAYBE JANUARY THE FIFTEENTH
INSTEAD OF MADE THIRTEEN THIS
ENVIRONMENT. AT FOR THE EIGHT
AS OPPOSED TO MY THE FIFTH IS
WORTH BILLION OF DOLLARS AND WE
WILLING TO TAKE A CHANCE USE
LOSE SOME TO BE THAT THE FACTS
THAT DO WORK ARE OUT THERE-
EARLIER WE'VE GOT- SENATE
COLLINS A BIG LEADER AND BEING
SURE WE HAD MONEY FOR THE
OPIOID ABUSE THAT ZUCKERBERG AS
PEOPLE FOUND THEMSELVES
ISOLATED AT HOME AND MAYBE OUT
OF WORK WITH ANOTHER PROBLEM
THERE AND THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND GET ABOUT FIVE
BILLION- ON THE SIDE OF THE
LEDGER THAT WOULD NOT BE THERE
IN A NORMAL. SPENDING YEAR
THERE'S OF HOSPITAL AND FOR.
AND OTHER FIVE BILLION FOR THEM
WITH THE REAL BIG DISCUSSION
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY
NEED TO SPEND ALL THE HOSPITAL
PROVIDER MONEY THEY CURRENTLY
HAVE. NOT SPENT WHICH IS ABOUT
SIXTY FIVE BILLION AT THAT
TWENTY FIVE BILLION TO IT AND
THEN SEE. HOW CLOSE OUR
PROVIDERS ARE TO WHERE THEY
WOULD BE IN A NORMAL YEAR WE
ASK HOSPITALS AND- DOCTORS
GENERALLY PROVIDERS GENERALLY
DO THE TWO HARDEST THINGS YOU
COULD DO. STOP YOUR INCOME AND
STAND READY FOR THE BIGGEST
HELP EMERGENY YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT YOUR HOSPITAL OR YOUR
PRACTICE WHATEVER HAVE TO DEAL
WITH. AND NOT JUST ON WORK OUT
VERY WELL SO ANOTHER TWENTY
FIVE. BILLION DOLLARS THERE.
YEAH. QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS I'M
KIDDING. I AM I THINK SENATOR
CALLS ALREADY OUTLINED- THAN
THE NEW OUT OF. THE PROPOSAL
AND LET ME LET ME JUST SAY THAT
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING A LOT NOW.
AS THE PPP MONEY RUNS OUT AS
THEY'RE BEGINNING TO LOOK AT.
NEW LAYOFFS WHICH I THINK IS
EVIDENCE OF THE FACT THAT HE
WAS HOPEFUL THE FACT THAT- BUT
AT THE SAME TIME IS ALSO
EVIDENCE. THAT WE ARE SEEING
RESURGENCE IS IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
PLACING NEW RESTRICTIONS
PLASTIC SYSTEM RESTRICTIONS FOR
MANY OF THESE BUSINESSES. IT'S
HARD TO SURVIVE UNDER AND THEN
OF COURSE THE CONSUMER BEHAVIOR
IS AFFECTED BY THE NEWS OF THE
PANDEMIC SO IT'S VERY TIMELY
AND IN ADDITION. TO PPP WHICH
IS NOW MORE TARGETED AT.
BUSINESSES UNDER THREE HUNDRED.
THIS RAMBLERS BUT WITH HIS SON
THREE HAD AND THE REVENUE
DAMAGE. IS SOMETHING WHAT WE'VE
SEEN PLAY OUT OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS AND THAT IS THAT-
BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY IN
UNDERSERVED AND MINORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS. ON AVERAGE THERE
WAS A RECENT STUDY THAT SAID
95% OF THEM HAD LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS OF CASH ON HAND. SO YOU
CAN FROM THAT IS HOW DIFFICULT
IT'S GOING TO BE FOR MANY OF
THEM TO SURVIVE NOT TO MENTION.
TO US TO. CAP OUR KIDS IN THE
FUTURE. SO SOURCE OF THIS PLAN
IN ADDITION TO PPP THERE IS A-
LONG TARGETED AT LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS. CENSUS TRACTS
THAT ARE EITHER IN AN
OPPORTUNITY ZONE OR IN A NEW.
MARKETS TAX CREDIT AREA. WHERE
THESE BUSINESSES CAN GET. TWO
TIME LET ALONE TO TRY YEARS ONE
FOR. OF TWO TIMES A THEIR
ANNUAL REVENUE. THESE ARE
COMPANIES THAT WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO OTHERWISE GAIN ACCESS
TO THAT SORT OF CAPITAL THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SURVIVE AND GROW
AND- REINVENT THEMSELVES. IN IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THIS PANDEMIC
AND- WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
IS AN UNEQUAL RECOVERY- AND SO
FOR US IT WAS IMPORTANT. TO
TARGET THAT- I THINK THIS IS
THIS IS OF A TIMELY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
WILL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE MANY
OF WHOM BENEFITED FROM PPP. AND
NOW MONTHS AND WHERE ARE.
STARING OUT OF THE CLERK AGAIN.
AND WORRIED WHAT FUTURE HOLDS
AND ARE MY EVERYBODY AGAIN. IS
NOT AVAILABLE THIS IS ABOUT
KEEPING PEOPLE ATTACHED. TO
THEIR EMPLOYMENT. AND THESE ARE
ABOUT RIVAL COMPANIES FOR
STRUGGLING BECAUSE OF
GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS
NECESSARY GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS. ARE THAT ARE
IMPACTING THEIR ABILITY NOT
JUST TO DO BUSINESS BUT THE
STANDARDS. BETTER STAFFED. IN
THE MONTH OF APRIL ABOUT ONE
OUT OF EVERY FOUR AMERICANS
LOST THEIR JOBS WORKED IN THE
RESTAURANT BUSINESS ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THE FINANCE
COMMITTEE IN FACT SIDE OF THIS
IS TO INCREASE THE DEDUCTION
FOR MEALS BUSINESS MAILS FROM
50% 21100% THAT WILL ENCOURAGE
MORE FOLKS TO SPEND MORE MONEY
AT RESTAURANTS FOR THE TAKE IT.
EASY ELEVEN THIS IN SOME STATES
THIS WEEK FIVE MILLION OF
DOLLARS THAT WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF HOURS WORKED BY THE
WAIT STAFF IN THE NUMBER OF
HOURS WORKED BY THOSE FOLKS
WORKING THERE JENNIFER LOOKING
MORE A WAY. TO HELP THE CARD IS.
AND BOTH THE SENATE. ONE OF THE
BEST ACTORS FOCUS. THIS
RESTAURANT SECTOR. AND THIS IS
WHAT THE PROVISIONS SOMETHING
ABOUT OFFICE. WE'D LIKE TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO ONE OF THE
ACTUALLY TWO OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE COVID
CRISIS THAT- THEY DESERVE THAT
ATTENTION AND PERHAPS DON'T
HAVE AS MUCH. THE PUBLIC
AWARENESS AS I THINK THEY OUGHT
TO. ONE IS AS A RESULT OF THE
COVID CRISIS WE'RE SEEING THE
TRUST FUNDS FOR MEDICARE AND
SOCIAL SECURITY APPROACH
INSOLVENCY ON A MUCH MORE RAPID
TIMETABLE THAT WE ANTICIPATED.
AND SECONDLY WE'RE ADDING UP A
LOT OF THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
OVER TWENTY SEVEN TRILLION
DOLLARS OF DEBT. AND THAT THAT
REQUIRES INTEREST TO BE PAID
EVERY YEAR. THAT DEATH HAS THE
POTENTIAL OF CREATING MORE
INFLATION DOWN THE ROAD AND OF
COURSE YOU COULD LEAD TO
POTENTIALLY TO AN ECONOMIC
CALAMITY WAY DOWN THE ROAD FOR
PEOPLE WHO COME BEHIND US AND
AS A RESULT REPUBLICANS THE
DEMOCRATS ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS. HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER AND THAT INCLUDES
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN. ACT YOURS
SENTIMENTS- ANGUS KING DOUG
JONES THIS IS A GROUP OF PEOPLE
COME TOGETHER AND MARK WARNER
ALONG WITH A OF ABOUT A DOZEN
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WE'VE ALL
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER TO SEE IF
WE CAN'T ADDRESS THIS AND IN
THE HOUSE. THERE ARE SOME
THIRTY DEMOCRATS AND THIRTY
REPUBLICANS THAT OF ALL WRITTEN
HOUSE LEADERSHIP AND SAID THIS
APPROACH OF THE TRUST ACT NEEDS
TO BE INCLUDED. IN THE NEXT
COVID RELIEF PACKAGE IN HEELS
ACT IF YOU WILL. AND APPROACH
IS QUITE SIMPLE WHICH IS WEEK
WE CREATED PROCESS A BIPARTISAN
BICAMERAL PROCESS. TO ADDRESS
EACH ONE OF THESE TRIPS TRUST
FUNDS INDIVIDUALLY. SO
COMMITTEE FOR EACH ONE OF THEM
TO LOOK AT HOW TO MAKE THEM
SOLVENT A LONG TERM BASIS AND
IF WE REACH A BIPARTISAN
CONCLUSION. BY CAMPBELL
CONCLUSION THAT CAN COME TO THE
FLOOR AN EXPERT ON THE BASIS WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS. THE SOLVENCY
OF OUR TRUST FUNDS THEY'RE
VITAL TO OUR SENIORS INTO OUR
ENTIRE NATION. WE ALSO HAVE TO
FINALLY DEAL WITH THE AMOUNT OF
DEBT THAT WE'RE ADDING UP. AS
WE RESCUE APPROPRIATELY. THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM THIS
TERRIBLE COLD ACROSS. I AM A
LAST ONE STANDING HERE. BIDEN
OKAY. YOU'RE WELCOME. THREE
FIVE. YEAH. YEAH IT IS GRATEFUL
TO THEM BE ABLE TO COME OUT OF
IT AND READ IT. IT BE DEMOCRAT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN INCOME ACT AND THAT
IS EXACTLY THAT IS NOT. THE
WHAT ARE YOU GOING. TO DO THREE
HUNDRED K. NOT. OFTEN WIFE NINE
THE FBI. I'M NOT THIS IS NOT.
MAYBE TWO OKAY. RIGHT NOW OKAY.
LOOK I THINK THIS A STARTING
PLACE YOU CAN SAY THAT WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS
INVOLVED AND THE START. AND WE
CAN'T PASS A BILL SENATE
WITHOUT DEMOCRAT NOR OBVIOUSLY
CAN PASS THE HOUSE. SO EVERY
BILL HAS TO START SOMEWHERE THE
REPUBLICANS ARE THE MAJORITY IN
THE SENATE. THIS IS THE
STARTING PLACE AND WE'LL GET
YOU ALL HAVE PLENTY OF STORIES
TO COVER ALONG THE WAY. AS WE
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS BACK AND
FORTH ACROSS PARTY LINES AND
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. YEAH.
YOU KNOW BILL ARE. SO IS THAT.
YOU COULD NOT LIVE OFF OF
BEYOND COVERAGE BECAUSE HE DID
NOT THAT THE AIRLINE- THE
CASHIER THERE WHAT OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES- THE LADY THAT I
DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER THE SECOND
ONE THAT THE FIRST ONE IS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY APPROPRIATED AN.
LOT OF MONEY FOR ELECTION
ASSISTANCE. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DO FEDERAL AMERICAN LEFT JUST.
WHICH IS BASIC CONDUCTED A
EVERYTHING STATE. IN VERY
DIFFERENT WAYS WE PROVIDED
PLENTY OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO TELL
THEM HOW TO CONDUCT. THERE ARE
ELECTIONS DURING THE PANDEMIC
OR MY VIEW AND A FUTURE EITHER
SO THAT'S WHY THERE'S NOT
ADDITIONAL MONEY IN THERE FOR
LIKE IN THE SYSTEM. I DON'T
HAVE BEEN AT YOUR SECOND
QUESTION I'M GONNA TAKE ONE
MORE THERE IS ONE. OR. IS ONE
OF OUR BUT WE ARE TALKING OR-
THE MOVIE. THE PROBLEM IS OUR.
WELL REGARDED THAT PROPOSAL
OBVIOUSLY WE HAD TO HAVE AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OR TO GET
STARTED AND THEY'LL AFTER. ADD
TO THE QUESTION OF WHY THEY
INSISTED ON THAT PROVISION
WE'RE- YOU'LL HAVE TO ASK THEM
WHY THEY INSISTED THAT BE
INCLUDED. OKAY THANK YOU.
THERE'S SOME.